[Music]
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
a global creative platform that makes it
easy for you to find an amazing designer
and create designs you'll love from
logos to branding to packaging to books
you name it they have it and I've used
them for just about everything 99
designs is the go to creative resource
for any budget I've used them for years
now for book covers for instance
mock-ups of the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number one New Times
bestseller illustrations for the
multi-volume Tao of Seneca including the
cover and many other creative projects
I've been very impressed by the quality
of their work most recently I used 99
designs to update the illustrations and
layout of my 5 morning rituals ebook the
illustrations worked out great I loved
working with the designer we selected
and I plan to work with him on more
projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the world will
submit concepts for you to choose from
you refined as you go give feedback and
once you're ready you choose one to
finalize it's a great way to get started
and find the right match a great
designer and a great design at a great
price so head to 99designs com forward
slash Tim to learn more or get started
today you can also see examples of some
of the work that I have done with
designers online and designs so check it
out
99 designs com forward slash tip
this episode is brought to you by humans
beat elite the product is beat elite not
meat elite not beat be EA T but beat be
ET elite which you might consider an
endurance superfood or what they would
call a nitric oxide activator really all
I care about is this product B Li was
introduced to me several years ago by a
multiple time world champion and has
since been recommended to me by multiple
world-class athletes and I use it pre
workout for endurance training that
could be cycling that could be swimming
it is very rarely running but my
subjective experience supports what some
of the research would seem to indicate
and that is that you can workout say up
to 15 to 18 percent longer if you're
looking at high-intensity interval
training hit for instance and at
recovery times so the let's call it the
refractory period for getting back to
peak power output for instance so I use
beat lay just use it this morning before
a 30-minute somewhat intense swim
workout and I have found that
particularly for someone like myself who
has really terrible endurance
genetically speaking my presets are
horrible that it really does allow a 10
to 20 percent boost in shorter workout
performance especially although I do
know people who have used it for 20 mile
runs 30 mile runs much longer endurance
events and they've got all sorts of
different points about the mechanisms of
action and so on but suffice to say that
it is a lot easier to consume beat elite
than to eat the nitric oxide equivalent
of six whole beats for instance much
more rapidly assimilated and it tastes
great it will also stain your pet
polar bear or your white cotton or your
down pillows so don't spill it on
anything but it does taste delicious I
tend to mix this into a shake that I
have pre-workout in the mornings so
there you have it
I've used beat elite for a number of
years now it is trusted by hundreds of
elite teams athletes and organizations
all over the world
and it is also informed sport certified
which means that it is certified to not
contain any banned substances so if
you're a competitive athlete that is one
fewer thing that you need to worry about
so take your performance to the next
level with beat elite try it out go to
live human calm slash to him to get 20%
off your first purchase the team at
human that's the company is making this
offer exclusive to you my dear listeners
so check it out go to live human dot-com
slash Tim super simple live human calm
slashed him give it a shot
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show aka Tim Tim talk talk
for you long-term listeners and yet it
is my opportunity and privilege again to
interview a world-class performer to try
to tease out the habits routines belief
systems lessons learned etc that you can
apply to your own life and the subject
today the interviewee is chairman and
chief executive officer of the Walt
Disney Company Robert a Iger also known
as Bob Iger you can say hello on Twitter
at Robert Iger IG er he is the steward
of one of the world's largest media
companies and some of the most respected
and beloved brands around the globe
since becoming CEO in 2005 Eiger has
built on Disney's rich history of
storytelling and innovation with the
acquisitions of Pixar in 2006 marvel in
2009 Lucasfilm in 2012 and 21st Century
Fox in 2019 these are gigantic deals and
we'll talk more about them and he's also
responsible for he was at the helm for
the landmark opening
Disney's first theme park and resort in
mainland China Shanghai Disney Resort in
2016 look up that just to get an idea of
the magnitude it is incredibly large and
speaking of incredibly large under his
watch Disney's value has roughly 5x - I
don't know what the exact stock price is
at the time of this recording but
quintupled quintupled the stock price
and the value of the company always want
to embrace new technology and that is a
huge asset in perspective that he's
brought to the table Iker has created an
ambitious direct-to-consumer strategy
that leverages Disney's unparalleled
creative content across new platforms
including the new Disney Plus streaming
service
ESPN Plus Hulu and hot star agar serves
on the boards of the National September
11 Memorial and Museum and Bloomberg
philanthropies he is a graduate of
Ithaca College his new autobiography is
titled the ride of a lifetime subtitle
lessons learned from 15 years a CEO of
the Walt Disney Company it's a great
read as someone who is obsessed with
deal making and structuring and
negotiating this book has tons of war
stories and lots of detail for anyone
who is similarly interested and I would
say overall the book is really less
about how to become a CEO although it
covers that and how to lead and more
about how to think about fear and live
with less fear metabolize fear
differently so with all that said please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with none other than Bob Iger
Bob welcome to the show thank you very
much nice to be here I have been
studying the path that you have traveled
to get to where you are and it's such an
embarrassment of riches from an
interviewing perspective it's hard to
know where to begin but I was taking a
look at a few different chapters in your
life and in your book and I thought we
might start with if you could tell the
story of your whiteboard session with
Steve Jobs and the the pro and con list
and he can give context however you
think is best
sure I called Steve Jobs with a crazy
idea the idea being that Disney should
buy Pixar and one of the things I
learned when you mentioned to Steve you
had a crazy idea he needed to hear it
right away
so even though I wanted to wait and tell
him in person he forced me to tell him
on the phone but instead of either
laughing me off the phone or rejecting
it summarily he invited me up to meet
him at Apple to discuss it further and
some time after the phone call that I
had made I found myself sitting in the
boardroom at the Apple headquarters in
Cupertino California alone at a long
long table with a whiteboard on the wall
that was as almost as long as the table
itself so many many feet and Steve said
we needed to have an exercise to discuss
the pros and cons of Pixar being bought
by Disney as I probably should have
expected Steve was the one that held the
writing instrument and stood at the
board so he was kind of the conductor of
the session in more ways than one and he
said something like you know you go
first and I didn't really have the guts
to go first I said no you go first
and he wrote pros and cons just as you
expect and started listing a set of cons
that were might seem like a mile long to
me they were so numerous
so much so that I said to him at some
point when he had said to me well you
why don't you name a few pros I said it
hardly seems worth it
you've listed so many cons that I don't
really see how we go forward and he said
no no you got to come up with a few and
I did I suggested a few actually tazed
credit my reckless I recollect he had a
couple as well but by the time we were
done with the exercise the list was
still far more tilted in the con
direction than the pro direction so I
reiterated to him my pessimism about
doing anything basically saying given
the fact that the cons are there's some
more numerous than the pros maybe
there's just this is just futile he said
no not at all just sometimes a couple of
really big pros are far outweigh many
many cons which I thought was quite
interesting he was able to look at this
list and not counts the sheer number of
items but tally up the kind of the
relative importance or lack thereof of
the items and that led to him saying
something like let's keep the door open
we should continue to talk about this
what do we need to do next and that led
to my saying I think I need to visit
Pixar I think I where the way I put it
see what's under the hood suggesting
that I look under and take take a really
close look at the engine that was Pixar
to see whether I could get at whether
the value was there for us to buy and
some of the cons that Steve put on this
board were seemingly so strong that you
couldn't possibly over overturn them or
outweigh them or counterbalance them in
the sense that some were Disney's
cultural world destroy Pixar yes your
board will never let you do it and yes a
distraction will kill Pixar's creativity
all caps thank you by the way you're
quoting from my book I don't have it in
front of me yeah but yes those were all
things that he said
of those three but by the way I think we
both felt that it was not a foregone
conclusion that the Disney Board would
would would let us do this but that was
not the biggest deterrent at least not
that day he had really really strong
feelings about the culture of Pixar and
the need to protect and preserve it and
his experience with Disney well it might
have been good at one point had turned
horribly bad and he viewed Disney as an
overly bureaucratic overly process
oriented not overly collaborative
culture and he thought that if we owned
Pixar that type of culture would
obliterate the culture that it was that
Pixar and he felt that Pixar culture was
more responsible for their creative
success than any one thing or any one
person and so and this actually played
out in great detail as the negotiation
wore on his desire to make sure that
even in a in a full-blown sale to Disney
the Disney would not in effect impose
its culture on Pixar to the detriment of
Pixar and that was a that was a theme
that not only dominated the negotiation
but actually once we went forward after
the deal was done we took a lot of steps
to see that that didn't happen I have a
few questions about this this specific
meeting and also your orientation going
into a meeting like that I recall
watching an interview you did some time
ago this is a few years ago with Kara
Swisher and Marc Andreessen on stage and
you were talking about how at one point
as it relates to earnings calls and so
on speaking publicly about the
challenges and the paraphrasing here of
course but the the difficult
perhaps obstacles or threats gives you
increased credibility then when you're
talking about the things that you're
excited about or optimistic about and
when I was reading this description of
the meeting I had to wonder what your
read of Steve was in the room as he was
writing down all these cons and and was
he playing the reluctant seller to hide
enthusiasm about possibly getting the
deal done or how did you interpret the
the feeling in the room at that at that
point I never detected that Steve was
ever acting or trying to act or saying
anything or trying to communicate and
convey anything to me other than what
was really true or what he really
believed that there was this was not a
charade in any way I think he was
intrigued with the notion of selling
Pixar which is not something he had been
thinking about very seriously but he
hadn't yet come to the conclusion that
it was the right thing to do he came to
the conclusion that it was a right thing
to seriously consider and so I felt that
everything he was putting on the table
in front of me or on the board in front
of me were things that he genuinely
believed or was was concerned about and
so authenticity was to me very apparent
that that that day and actually it was
always the case with him as I came to
both both learn and appreciate I had
read in a separate profile and please
correct me if I'm getting this wrong
that Steve used to call you now it says
Saturday mornings I don't know if it was
limited to Saturday mornings when he
thought a film was a dud because that is
that true could you elaborate Steve I
sense while he liked his his quiet time
and he liked to be still
never allowed himself to be quieter
still for too long and weekend sometimes
I think got a little quiet for him and
so he would call me on a fairly regular
basis on weekends and actually say I was
just bored so I called you I think I
said that in there I don't think I wrote
that in the book but so the calls were
and often not about anything just about
things in other words hey let's talk you
know it's Saturday morning
he's usually late Saturday morning or
late Saturday afternoon let's just chat
like what are you doing and what I loved
about those calls is he was generous to
I could easily ask him the question well
what are you doing and there are times
he'd go into a dissertation about some
product he was developing at Apple is
for instance so it became like almost
this private lecture series that I was
participating in I came to really
appreciate those those calls and there's
one particular one that that you
mentioned he called Saturday with
something specific on his mind it was
actually I think a Sunday that time and
he said hey how are you
which was very quick often I went to the
movies last night with my son Reed and
we saw Iron Man 2 and it sucked like
boom boom boom boom boom not I can give
me a chance to say are you saw Iron Man
- that's nice no it was a right
stream-of-consciousness no pause I saw
Iron Man - and it sucked
oh I remember saying to him that's
interesting you know I respect your
opinion but it's not consistent with the
opinion of many others it did extremely
well like you know the audience voted
and they liked it and he chuckled he
said well I just I thought it was
terrible and so did read what was it
that was it and I I think I said at that
point well you're entitled to your
opinions like one of the things that I
loved about my relationship with him and
I give him all the
for this is he quickly brought our
relationship to the point where he could
say things to me that were honest and
sometimes well harsh in a way but
without meaning to harm anybody in other
words I never felt threatened he
challenged me but he I never felt
threatened or abused or or criticized
the point of it damaging me or my
reputation over my or my my relationship
with him so I'd love to hop backwards in
time or although I suppose the
recollection of this is present tense
but for people who don't know the name
and I looked up some video to try to
ensure I'm pronouncing this correctly
ruin Arledge that name came up very
close to the whiteboard story that we
were discussing in the following context
one of the things I've always
instinctively felt I'm quoting here and
something that was greatly reinforced
working for people like rune and Michael
is that long shots aren't usually as
long as they seem
could you describe what you mean by that
and how that was taught to you or how
you absorbed it from say rune in this
example Roone Arledge was president of
ABC sports when I started at ABC Sports
in the mid 70s
and someone I work for for 10 years he
worked for me for 10 years as well and
then he also became president of ABC
News and he established a reputation in
both places as being a gigantic risk
taker a showman an innovator and and
someone with an incredible eye for a
great story and he's given credit for
basically being the father of modern day
television sports coverage and one of
the reason which he deserved by the way
and one of the reasons he gets that
credit
is that he was willing to try a lot of
big things things that had not been done
before and did go places that no one had
ever gone tell stories that no one ever
told just they generally he was quite an
innovator and one of the things that I
quickly learned from rune is he had a
lot of big ideas that he would turn then
to his team which I was a member and
asked us to implement them and it's very
easy sometimes when someone brings a big
idea to you to say well that's almost
impossible to to do or this will never
happen or I don't know how I get that
done but working for him you quickly
learn that he didn't take no for an
answer and he expected you to pull out
all the stops never by the way forcing
us to you know suffer a loss of
integrity or do something that wasn't
morally correct but he certainly
believes that all the energy in the
world should be should be applied to
getting a tough task done or all the
ingenuity and I loved particularly in my
20s when I started working for him
I loved that lesson because he didn't
take no for an answer and I think
there's a lot of value in that so he
could ask us to do things I remember
once he asked me when I was a lowly
programmer for a program called ABC's
Wide World of Sports to get the rights
to the world Table Tennis Championships
which were going to be taking place in
Pyongyang North Korea as if for instance
not the easiest thing in the world to
even figure out how to do but it
resulted in meetings in Beijing and with
the North Koreans and ultimately getting
the rights and then having to deal with
the US State Department it wouldn't let
ABC Sports pay the North Koreans
directly because of sanctions and having
to pay in a world Table Tennis
Federation out of Wales the money they
would then go to the North Koreans and
so on and so on a near Herculean task
that in ruins mind was never
particularly Hercules
something he felt we should do and if
and we got the rights through tremendous
amount of perseverance and ingenuity and
sent a crew into Pyongyang North Korea
and I think 1979 what I remember is that
it was the first u.s. crew of any kind
television crew of any kind that went to
Pyongyang since before the Korean War
you as you strike me and have have
always struck me as as I've followed
much of what you've done in the world as
an exceptionally good and creative deal
deal maker and I would love to know how
that if that's I mean I'll take it to be
true but where that was cultivated or
who helped you to develop that skill to
think through something that others
might give up on like this task you were
given and to find the workarounds to
look for the possibilities instead of
just staring at the obstacles who helped
to cultivate that in you or teach you
that ability to deal make well as I
think back on this Odyssey of a career
and I'm often asked kind of how did you
get were you where you are and I will
answer the question directly but three
things are come to mind in terms of
contributing to my success to are not
relevant to this question hard work and
luck the third one is mentorship I
worked for some incredibly talented
people talented creatively talented from
a pure business perspective and they
either consciously and proactively
taught me a lot or I simply learned by
watching them learning learning from
them through observation and one would
would be the the ability to negotiate
and Michael Eisner was great at that I
ruin Arledge was great at that a few
other of my bosses that at ABC sports a
man named Jim Spence was particularly
good at it just people that were
constantly kind of going head to head
with some
today that was selling something that we
wanted to buy knowing that they had to
buy it because it was important to the
organization they needed to get it fast
so that no one else did and they needed
to get it the best possible price and so
I watched people do that and you know
not only how to get the best outcome but
how to get the best outcome the fastest
and or how to even convince someone who
wasn't even intent on selling something
to sell it to us which was the case in
with Steve at that point he was the case
with George Lucas you know a number of
years later with Lucasfilm is a case
with our Ike Perlmutter and Marvel these
were businesses that were not
necessarily for sale that you know we
had first convinced I guess I did in all
three cases them to sell and then
convince them to sell at a price that
made the most sense not only for us but
for them as well but I had great I
worked for great people and for over a
long period of time you know was I I was
in the business for thirty years before
I got the job as CEO of the Walt Disney
Company 30 years that's a lot that's a
long education it's a long education and
I would say that I you seem to have done
a very good job of learning lessons and
then implementing skills along the way I
mean there are people who make the same
mistakes for 20 years or 30 years or
more and you've evolved over time when
you look back at whether it's save Jim
Spence or the other people that you
named or your own experience what what
are some of the things that separate a
good negotiator from a great negotiator
because the the criteria that you
mentioned for some of these negotiations
getting getting the deal done quickly
getting the best price possible if form
I what would seem to be a pretty
difficult cocktail so what what in your
mind separates the a players from the B
players from a negotiation standpoint
well I think first of all this is the
thing that set a good negotiator apart
from a bad negotiator is one that gets a
deal done
yes right it starts there and in a way
that I think is satisfactory to both
sides I've always been a big believer
and this is sort of cliche but you know
negotiation should be should work both
ways to the buyer and the seller should
come away both feeling good about it or
maybe not both not feeling good about it
I'm not sure but I happen to believe
that a good negotiation is one that is
conducted efficiently and effectively I
don't think it's something that should
be necessarily protracted because it
takes a lot of time and energy it should
be one where the value that is seen by
the buyer is delivered through the
transaction by the transaction which
means that the price in the
circumstances ought to in some form or
another conform to the value proposition
that's really important
I like being very honest I like getting
to the heart of a negotiation fairly
quickly I like putting my cards on the
table instead of keeping them completely
close to one's vest
there are times though in a negotiation
where I found you do have to get up and
walk away from the table if the terms
that you're looking at just do not make
sense and be willing to lose a deal if
you can't get the right terms I've done
that a number of times but that's I
think just good honest negotiating you
know I don't approach negotiations with
the need to win I didn't hire a person
with a need with a desire to close a
deal I guess winning that certainly
contributes to winning closing a deal
but I mean winning I mean winning on all
points on all terms etc it's not
necessary to me what do you say to your
team or at different points your bosses
or other people who with within your
organization we're hoping for a deal to
get done that you've rejected because
you could not get the terms that you
wanted is is there any way that you
you've learned to communicate that to
other people who are part of a team who
may have had more of an emotional
attachment to us to a certain outcome or
is everybody just on the same page from
the get-go and you don't have to have
that conversation no I usually like to
have a conversation with some member of
my team who was entering in or embarking
on a negotiation to get something I
usually like is that an understanding
about what what the expense of the of
the that whatever the acquisition is
will be in other words set parameters go
out and get it provided it's within a
certain guidelines or expectations and
if you can't get it at that walk away or
let's have one more discussion I like I
like those that are negotiating on our
behalf on things that matter to the
company it's the point where they're
brought to my attention to know at what
point walking away is acceptable at what
point in effect not getting something is
okay because it's it's it's not if it's
no longer affordable or it's no longer
justifiable from a from an economic
perspective is that what you're trying
to get at here yeah but yeah that's
that's I think what I'm getting at and I
think what I'm also kind of not
tiptoeing but moving and circling around
is a broader topic of risk-taking you
mentioned that rune was a risk taker you
have a reputation as a risk taker but
from at least what I can see you strike
me is also very systematic very
calculated in the best possible way what
was your first or any early exposure to
risk taking whether your own or someone
else's that you learned from does
anything come to mind as early
influences in that regard well I saw a
lot of risk-taking at ABC sports but it
was like looking back they're kind of
quaint risks or modest risks
just think about what some of those were
but I mean the groom was one who stepped
up early on and spent big money on
buying rights to the Olympic Games
into covering sports just say the Alinta
olympics that were not necessarily
sports that America was that familiar
with and their athletes who were not in
any way household names but he believed
that he could he could turn the Olympic
Games into into or find the stories and
the Olympic Games that would be of great
interest to people throughout America
regardless of what country the athlete
was from regardless of what sport they
were in as a for instance I just watched
that happen time and time again with
them looking at the picture that the
headlines paint of your various mega
successes I'd love to go all the way
back to the very beginning at ABC and
correct me if I'm getting this wrong but
I I want to say that you've mentioned
that your first boss at ABC said you
weren't promotable is that true and if
so why why were you looked at as
unpromoted he was a it turns out he was
a thief and he got fired actually I
think he was led out of the building I'm
told I wasn't there when it happened but
I think possibly with law enforcement
people present because he had been
caught embezzling but at the time we
were we were covering an event in New
York and we had to get some pickup
trucks for the event and this is really
kind of obscure but this is how it
happened and I juked to some where there
was a coincidence that I was moving
apartments in New York that weekend
wouldn't it be great if I could use the
pickup truck over the weekend to move my
furniture I was actually just joking
they because the pickup truck wasn't
even in my possession they passed that
along to this particular boss who
was threatened by me already because I
had been reluctant to carry out some of
the orders that he had wanted carried
out mainly using company property for
his personal gain and so he already saw
me as a threat
and when he heard this he called me into
his office he never challenged me at all
on the pickup truck issue at all but he
simply said I don't really believe you
have a future here in fact Eiger you're
not promotable and I'm giving you two
weeks to find another job in this
company or I'm gonna fire you and it
wasn't until later that I found out that
what it's wood had sparked this was
someone spreading a rumor that I was
potentially gonna use the pickup truck
which is just silly so so what then
happened in the subsequent two weeks
well I was I took him very seriously and
I there was a job posting system at the
company he's kind of funny how quaint it
was then this is 1975 where there was a
a clipboard and yet the lobby near the
lobby of most of the buildings that ABC
was in and on the clipboard were
postings of open jobs of the company in
various divisions so I literally left
his office went down and looked at this
clipboard to see whether there are other
jobs at the company that I might see
myself doing so that I could get out of
harm's way and lo and behold there was a
job at ABC Sports
and what was coincidental about that is
that I had been assigned to work on a
Frank Sinatra concert at Madison Square
Garden and it was produced by Roone
Arledge
who was head of ABC Sports so roon
brought a lot of his ABC sports
production executives over to help
produce the Frank Sinatra concert so
when I saw this job ABC sports on the
job posting system I called people I had
worked with on the concert they
immediately said we'll come on over and
we'll talk about it and because they
knew me from the work I had done on the
answered they said they hired me on the
spot so it could have talked about luck
contributing greatly to my success it
was just a matter of luck that had
worked on that show and that ruin had
produced it and that the very people who
would save me from this boss who would
deem me unpromoted
were people that I had worked with some
months earlier and we're willing to take
me in which proved to be just fantastic
I worked at ABC Sports for 13 years ten
of them for ruin Arledge and worked my
way up to the point where I had been
senior vice president programming at ABC
Sports which then led me to other big
jobs at ABC all coming from that one
moment of one being called unpromoted
then going to a job posting system
finding a job so wild how the little
things the seemingly little things yes
coalesce at these points I think that's
true in life in many respects you know
our lives in a way or a collection of
little things little occurrences that
loom large and become much bigger as you
know life goes on it's and turn
basically completely changed the
direction of your life you know based on
something you never would have expected
could or would that's it's really
remarkable and it also brings to mind
you know reading about many of your
experiences and I'm blanking on the
attribution of this but I read an essay
not too long ago that talked about
something called the luck surface area
so not to discount luck as a factor but
that there are things you can do to
increase the surface area on which luck
can stick if it happens to cross your
path and I do like to explore habits in
this podcast and one of the there are a
number of habits that come to mind as it
relates to your life what is one is
exercise and it seems to be something
you take very seriously and I'm
wondering if you could speak to what
role you feel exercise of fitness has
has played in your trajectory or
I in in life I suppose broadly speaking
I can dig into more specifics of helpful
but I'd love to do it I'd be glad to
describe that and respond specifically
but I also want to come back to that
whole notion of you know can you
increase the incidence of luck or can
you position yourself in a way that
takes better advantage of of luck than
then and others perhaps so on
specifically regarding exercise I
exercise really for three reasons one is
health
the second is vanity and the third is
sanity the health part my parents both
had heart attacks at 40 Wow and I
learned at an early age that the the a
healthy lifestyle could ultimately save
my life they live till they were 85 by
the way both of them but they didn't
live healthy lives and I wanted to lead
a healthy life and a long life so I
changed my diet and exercise it pretty
much an early age I'd say it 20 or 20
certainly under 25 years old second I
like to look good you know maybe we all
have a little bit of vanity in us I
guess you could argue that maybe looking
good is a contributing factor to success
at least research suggests that it is
I've never really thought of it that way
but keeping myself fit just look better
makes me feel better and then the third
is actually just as important as the
first and that is I need quiet time I
need alone time I need a time to be
still with my thoughts and exercise
provides that for me it's solitude
except for one day a week when I take a
bike ride with friends I pretty much
exercise alone I have a trainer come in
a couple of days after I've exercised
alone but I exercise alone six days a
week and it gives me the time to dream
to think to create to organize to
prioritize
to reflect you name it and I find
there's an energizing quality to all of
that but there's also a calming quality
and it has served me extremely well
Elvis to the point of being a savior of
sorts meaning in in the most I don't
know fresher times and the busiest times
in times of either the most uncertainty
or the most concern I have that quiet
time to exercise and give me a chance to
he the rejuvenate or put things in
perspective so huge value to that what
for instance this week you could pick
any day yesterday today tomorrow what
what does your regimen look like
distance in terms of specifics what like
what time of day what how long what type
of exercises what what is what are these
what are the details look like well
today is slightly abnormal but not not
very because I flew to New York from LA
late yesterday afternoon
so last night would be my first night on
so the East Coast time this week but I
got up at 4:30 and 15 minutes later I
was on what's called the Versa climber
which I have in my apartment in New York
it's my go-to cardio exercise during the
week I ride a bike on weekends and it's
not necessarily for the faint of heart
it's something I've been doing since
maybe 1991 or 1992 and it simulates
climbing it's a post that goes into the
air maybe about 10 feet and it has hand
grips and foot pedals and and and you've
raised your arms and your legs and
coordination and it's as though you're
climbing up either a ladder or stairs on
the side of a building and I listen to
music when I do that I have a television
on but with no sound and I listen to I
like listening to music every day too so
I I have numerous playlists or I'll just
listen to an artist
an album and sometimes I can close my
eyes because I'm I'm basically tied into
this thing and some for like a fall off
you don't have to have your eyes you're
not gonna run into anything because she
you're in one machine so I did that for
45 minutes and did a little bit of
stretching and some ball work afterwards
had a cup of coffee and read and looked
at the newspaper and and got on with my
day
it's obvious the obvious needs to shower
and shave and put on your your work duds
in it and out the door I went and about
this morning about 7:30 what do you put
on the television that you have on mute
it's either a local news show or one of
our TV stations if I'm in in the States
or ESPN if I'm outside the country tip
can there's a TV in the gym that I'm
working at and it's typically not within
my control I've watched many a Chinese
television news program or or or soap
opera boy
yeah there's another time we can talk I
know you've spent a lot of time in China
I actually went to two universities in
China a long long time ago and we ended
up the students in this dorm at foreign
experts dormitory they called it would
watch these Kung Fu soap operas effect
yeah to pick up the the language which
was turned into a really pleasant
routine on the at one point it was a
foreign experts hotel in Beijing and
that still exists foreign experts
building yeah Beijing it's it was a very
flattering it was very flattering term
to have applied to us while keeping us
conveniently separated from the rest of
the student population but it was a
fascinating time this was this was not
to digress too far but this was back
when the and I'm sure you remember these
days the when the bicycles I mean the
sea of bison was still a phenomenon
and remember by late 90s actually yeah I
was there in 96 and it was still when as
a as a poor student we would buy these
long green People's Liberation Army
jackets for the winter and what a trip
yeah I remember most then about China
then was yet the bicycles would be on
the top of the list the fact that people
were no colored clothing really it was
down either black or gray or dark green
very dry there yeah there were no colors
and in the winter people would stand on
street corners with with he's a pieces
of charcoal or burning things or cook
either cooking or burning to keep warm
so there was a smell of charcoal in the
air throughout Beijing yeah in the
winter
yeah it's changed a lot it has changed
tremendously I mean not not a back then
not a not a Gucci or Prada store in
sight or Mercedes or Marcedes a Ferrari
or a Nike for that matter or doesn't it
yeah yeah things have changed a lot but
before I totally lose the thread because
I'm so interested in this particular
facet among others the only exercise
front you mentioned that you do your
solitary working out and then have a
trainer come in at least a few twice a
week what do you do solo on those days
and what do you do with the trainer I do
I'd limit myself to only 30 minutes on
the Versa climber and he comes in
afterward and we lift weights and
stretch at the ripe old age of 68
lifting weights alone could be just a
little dangerous yeah so he helps me
first of you motivates me he's actually
a friend too so it's nice interaction he
shows up at the house at five and twice
a week when I lay him you know he's a
nice guy he's a good friend and and he
makes sure that I don't kill myself he
pushes me enough but then the
within some guidelines to stay safe and
I like that I I've read from a diet
perspective that you don't eat much in
terms of carbs but that you do love
pizza is this is this accurate yeah I I
I don't eat bread or pasta you know save
for the very occasional it's a holiday
so I allow myself a bowl of pasta but I
gave up all bread I'll never have a
sandwich I had a turkey burger for lunch
today without the button that's sort of
typical but I am a pizza devote a and it
is one of my vices
there aren't many and I allow myself a
good Pizza meal maybe once a month maybe
sometimes I stretch it to - those are my
carbs that do you have a favorite pizza
I mean if you have is there a specific
pizza that is your go-to now
favorite item and I try to find a good
pizza and in any place that I go there
are many but no I'm I'm not really
favorite in the sense that any pizza is
a good well there's of course just a an
ocean of fantastic pizza in New York
there's a lot of good pizza in many
places Austin where I'm sitting right
now also has some really good pizza
surprisingly home slice and a number of
others so the next time you're here that
could be that could be allocated to that
the sanity bucket yes what I do what I
do though is I find myself because also
a lot written about food lately and
whenever I see an article about great
pizza in a city I save it so the most
recent one was a New Yorker article
which is about the slice renaissance in
New York meaning pizza by the slice
mm-hmm it appeared maybe two or three
weeks ago in New York so there's a they
let they listed a place called norms in
downtown Brooklyn that I'm destined to
try out this holiday vacation but so I
guess a Renaissance of pizza by the
slice how
when you find something like that at
this New Yorker article how do you save
it what is the actual process of saving
something like that I'd say I copy a
late I read The New Yorker on this app I
copy a link or I copy the whole article
and I put it on a email and I send it to
myself so I literally sent I've shared
the sliced Renaissance with you from The
New Yorker with a link that said
something like Paulie G's pizza by the
slice or something like that in the lake
and that sits and that I'm now looking
at it I just pulled it up and I sent it
to myself on November 18th mm-hmm so
here I am in New York and I will refer
to that link and my son's or 21 and 17
and like pizza will come in and the two
of the three of us on Friday or Saturday
will put our our cold-weather coats on
and head out into the cold New York air
and looking for a good slice of pizza ha
that sounds perfect
it sounds so much more appealing than
then like warm and sticky plus pizza
like the cold actually really lends
something to it that's right it's funny
I think I've had pizza in Austin but I
don't remember from where there's a
pretty deep there's a decent selection I
mean it is a food town do you limit
yourself to do you have a heart cut off
at one slice or do you allow yourself to
let loose what I let loose if I'm
sitting down having a pizza it's a
special moment and I think one slice
with one piece one slice would not do it
I see there's an eater Austin or of
course totally off track here but I'm
now looking this sano pizzeria little
deli pizzeria pint house pizza any of
those Maritimes coal-fired yeah pint
houses right next to a paleo restaurant
so you could go to picnic P IC n I K
this is on Burnett Road for ya got your
paleo meal in the morning and then walk
50 feet after a coffee to have the pizza
at pine
so that right I see his number net road
yeah funny that's one thing by the way
thanks to the internet Oh Daesan oh is
on Burnett Road too is you can pretty
much find good pizza in any town in the
world thanks to the Internet just just
all you have to do is best pizza in and
you get a pretty good list
Shazam see I love to ask you about
preparation I was texting with Adam
grant who's been on this podcast and you
you recently spoke on stage and we're at
Wharton and we're very generous with
students which Adam really appreciated
and the I I was texting with him asking
him what he thought might make a good
topic or question to explore and one of
the things that he mentioned not was
quote here I don't think he would mind
he prepares this is he meaning you
prepares a lot more than most CEOs for
meeting new people maybe partially
because he's an introvert which he
mentioned on stage what's his prep
process do you have a prep process for
first meetings with certain types of
people yes I I don't I don't have the
time to prep for everyone right I'd say
75% of the time I do and it's actually
quite easy I'll just go to the internet
and type someone's name and I'll often
first look at a Wikipedia page just to
get a general sense and then I'll see
some things I liked it like for instance
you know in your case I want to look at
things that you've done I try to look at
work I'll try to look at news to see if
there's something particularly new about
you my recollection about you that stood
out as you went you either were born in
East Hampton or you grew up there I was
townie with a rat tail in the Hamptons
yeah and I was a Long Island boy after I
born in Brooklyn mm-hmm
so that struck me is interesting and
then coincidentally I the person who
helps me manage my money when he heard
that I was writing a book
said many many months ago that the if
I'm gonna sell books the person I should
ultimately sit down and talk with is you
well please please thank him thank him
for the content he did that because he I
was at tim geithner
i can't remember what he was one someone
that you interviewed that he had heard
anyway but i typically will do nothing
it's not overly interesting research i
think but i try to just get a feel for
somebody you know whether they sometimes
it's a small thing whether they have
kids or not you know where they're from
how old they are even every once in a
while find out someone you know may have
the same birthday as I do or I don't
know there'd be something it'll stand
out that just enables me to connect with
that person in some more meaningful way
than and just sort of a you know a road
interview well a little bit goes a long
way and I I want to jump from the the
micro to maybe its macro but I've
certainly read numerous instances of you
talking about the importance of optimism
as a leader and I think I read a quote
that you'd mentioned unify low e or
right Oh bother
and I've been thinking a lot about this
recently for a whole host of reasons and
you mentioned your son's 21 and 17 how
have you if you've thought about it
consciously taught your kids to see the
world through a lens of optimism are
there I hate to use this word but
mantras are there books that you
recommend how how do you cultivate that
in your kids if you've thought about it
now I have thought about it I don't know
that it's the first lesson then or the
most important lesson that I'm teaching
them but and some of I find what you do
in educating your kids is delete is you
teach my example where you lead by
example I
and I talk about optimism often but I
want to make sure that people understand
what that means I think there's it's
important to be a realist so I'm not one
of these that believe that everything
will work out fine all the time but I do
believe that making sure that the
possibility of something working out
fine is very apparent is the right there
instead of the opposite this will never
work out where there's no way we will
accomplish this or there's no way we can
do this and it's part of it is I hate to
use the word stick or the term
stick-to-itiveness but it's it's having
the it's being it's having the being
able to be persistent I guess really
working hard trying hard to get
something done or accomplished
instead of it's kind of what I talked
about earlier even with rune instead of
immediately concluding well this can't
happen or this won't happen so it's I
guess that's in part aimed at doing and
being productive getting things done
but I think it also applies to outlook
on life or aspects of your life I think
if you look at everything through a dark
lens meaning meaning dark and gloomy
lens then you tend to I think it becomes
a deterrent to having the energy to be
happy or having the energy for things to
actually work out right it just creates
a negative energy as opposed to the
opposite I think you need a positive
energy for your life to be positive so
it's it's not it's it's not accepting
the negative in a variety of different
ways but instead accepting the
possibility of things being positive
turning out all right right the the
conversation so far with the exception
of the the first boss at ABC and at the
truck fiasco have focused on some of
your successes and it's a long list but
some of your sick
asses have to try to flesh out the the
picture of you as a human being would
you be open to describing a more
challenging time that you've gone
through and how you have navigated your
way through it or out of it and I mean
any example would do but would you be
open to sharing for people who might
otherwise be intimidated and think oh
this guy hits a home run every time he
steps up to the plate That's not me
therefore whatever conclusion they might
come to is is there a a difficult
experience or a difficult time that you
could talk about navigating first of all
I don't know I have no problem
whatsoever talking about such things
interestingly enough I don't see myself
as a person that hits a home run every
time he steps up at the plate maybe
because I'm not convinced that the next
time I step up at the plate I'm gonna
hit a home run or that every time I step
up I will write I don't you think I
think of the possible as I said a few
minutes ago I always think there's a
possibility but I never believed that
it's a given ever and so I don't really
view myself as someone that succeeds at
everything I do
because I don't know that I will and
I've been fortunate that I've succeeded
in a lot of what I have done but it
doesn't mean that I will succeed at
everything I tried to do i I think the I
haven't I have not fortunately in my
adult professional life have faced I
faced challenges but not much adversity
what I mean by that is I don't really
remember any particularly dark period of
time where other than I want to talk
about the succession process which I
wrote about at length but other than
that I haven't really experienced that
while I was trying to become the next
CEO of the Walt Disney Company
there was a conventional wisdom that it
was existed and was very very apparent
to me
that I would not get the job or that I
was the wrong person for the job
and so there I faced a significant
number of naysayers that in even some
cases that tried to convince me that I
shouldn't even try because I was not
going to get it I'm not going to win and
I never gave in to that but I will say
that for a considerably long period of
time meaning well over a year I faced a
lot of doubters that if there was a
struggle it was making sure that those
that were doubting me did not cause me
to doubt myself even though I was if the
outcome was thoroughly uncertain I never
got to the point where I felt it was
completely uncertain and as long as it
wasn't or as long as it was open I was
going to continue to try really hard to
get the job that was that would one and
then we can talk further if you'd like
about the adversity I faced with a
father that was suffering from severe
manic depression which was more of a
that was a childhood experience that I
had versus an adult experience well
let's let's talk about if you're open to
it thank you for putting that on the
table the challenges were your
experience with your father had a
conversation not long ago with Ken Burns
the documentarian who also had a father
who I think in this day and age would
probably be diagnosed with bipolar or
manic depression there was a current DSM
diagnosis is could you could you speak
to that experience and what that was
like for you yes I recognized from a
very early age that my father had severe
mood swings and meaning he did not
present himself consistently to to us as
a family and that was manifested in a
variety of different ways but the one
that I
he used the example I used to describe
it as he would come home he commuted to
New York City to a suburb that we lived
in that was about an hour away I could
be up in my room on the second floor of
our house to a homework or something and
I could hear the door open and I would
always anticipate him coming home
because meant that we were going to have
dinner together and I look forward I
look forward to seeing him most of the
time but I could typically tell what
kind of a mood II was in my how he
walked up the steps sometimes passing my
room completely because he was not in
the mood or sometimes opening the door
and expressing some frustration about
something and sometimes not sometimes
showing interest in love and giving me
time and and being just generally upbeat
about things but it was very very
inconsistent and I remember that from an
early age I also witnessed him lose his
temper in in in ways that never made us
feel like we were in harm's way or that
anything bad was gonna come of us
physically but he could get angry very
fast and he did so very often and the
anger was not particularly pretty to
look at this was not just someone you
know getting mad at something and then
getting over it this was the deep-seated
anger at someone or something expressed
in in pretty dark ways meaning again not
apparent abhorrent behavior and not
something you'd say this guy's a
psychopath but he you could clearly see
him be in or go to a very dark place
what is how do you relate to anger after
all of that experience if you feel anger
arise in you how do you how do you
relate to anger and I know that's a very
broad question but this is something
that I also can think about for my own
sort of personal
navigation of life but how do you relate
to anger I think it's actually I think
it's a good thing to think about I I
know when I was really young that I had
a tendency to to to lose my temper like
him and I as I got more and more in tune
with his issues I became more and more
capable of controlling mine and I was
able to suppress my expression of anger
in a very very effective way and that
has served me well and lasted pretty
much a lifetime I feel sometimes a
building in me but I am I am able to
recognize either what it is or where it
could go and take the necessary steps to
to contend with it in a healthy way
sometimes means letting it surface but
letting it surface in ways that are
neither aggressive or as potentially
harmful to me or to others but I learned
I definitely learned to contain my
movement my anger maybe even how I
expressed my mood because of him I did
not it was a picture I was seeing of
someone's behavior and I even before I
had an ability to understand exactly
what the root cause of it was that I did
not in any way want and I did not want
that picture to become my life or part
or to basically maybe the center of it I
was so anger has been an emotion that
I've I struggled with for a very long
time I think I've improved quite a bit
for I think some very similar reasons
with similar origin stories and I was
reading a profile in the New York Times
and jumped up chuckling because this is
sort of deja vu all over again for me as
well so it here's here's the quotes as
you know I'm very organized and neat if
I got into the kitchen and willows been
in that's your wife and she leaves a
cabinet open
there was a time when I would actually
get mad at that you've got to be kidding
why would I get mad at something like
that it's pausing for a moment thinking
does this really matter so I'm curious -
I'd be curious to hear from you because
I think this will sort of ring familiar
for a lot of people listening what
changed between the it used to upset you
and now you are able to kind of digest
an experience like that that previously
would have maybe thrown you off in in
some way or just irritated you what what
has changed well I think some people
improve with age not everybody but
maturity having the ability as you get
older to recognize what is important
about life understanding sometimes the
hard way by losing people you're close
to that life in fact is not it is not
endless that it's and in fact it's it's
short and the understanding that because
of that that there are things in life
that just over are not I'm not important
enough don't rise to a level of of
causing anger sorrow conflict or
whatever and keeping cabinets open the
kitchen is one of them by the way I
still I'm borderline at times my wife
likes to keep newspapers that have you
know piled up for a week and it used to
be a time when I would just done like a
Wednesday I throw out Mondays and
Tuesdays just I didn't like the clutter
you know I I just see them I pause for a
moment thinking why do we really need
those newspapers piled up then I realize
well what the heck do I care
what's the difference why does that
matter to walk away right Owens the same
thing that sort of walk away and do not
allow things that really don't matter to
matter
make sure that the things that really do
matter in fact matter it's kind of that
simple and I don't know
I think poor again it's age it's it's
trying to be self-reflective your own
behavior and
what it can mean to others and sort of
the old don't sweat the small stuff it's
very true but you know I know we're all
human beings we all can and there's
still some things as I said and I don't
like being late I get very anxious about
that you know like it's just again I
think a lot of it comes from from not
only maturity but it's almost the
there's a cruelty to growing old in a
way because it means the end is near but
there's also a lot of value in growing
old yeah I would imagine I mean I'm I'm
certainly I don't feel old but I'm 42 or
43 I always forget my girlfriend
reminded me the other day so that may
not be a great sign it was okay he's 10
years younger so she's gone she's got a
leg up in more ways than one but she
yeah she's she reminds me of how old I
am but I've noticed that even compared
to say my 20s that I have to be more
aware of energy expenditure right manly
and I do exercise I do everything that I
can to maintain fitness but it I would
imagine as you get older also like if
you do let the small stuff sweat you
you're just going to kind of brush off
all of this extra energy that would be
better allocated elsewhere and maybe
it's more obvious I don't know just uh
yeah thinking out loud I think that's
some of it yes it's where it's
completely wasted energy when you think
about it both physical and emotional
energy when we were talking about
optimism and I asked you about your your
kids one of the comments you made was
I'm not sure if that would be the most
important lesson or something along
those lines you what do you feel some of
the more important lessons
might be or character traits that you
are hoping to instill or heaven stilled
in your kids well big one is well there
are Fletcher Pig ones being humble keep
it in perspective really important
understand we try always to help them
understand that we lead an extremely
special life privileged life that it
didn't happen by accident and it
shouldn't be expected they shouldn't
expect that it will happen to them but
and they do they have to they have to
want to appreciate it to work for it and
simply not take things for granted it's
really important I think that's one I'm
a big believer in being true to oneself
until you're true to oneself you can't
be true to others we try to teach that
to the kids in various ways but has to
do with being sort of self honest and
and which is not easy to teach teenage
boys by the way how do you at what would
be one of the approaches that you take
with that of one of the various ways
that you might try to teach that or
coach that well that's a very good case
for it's about question you know think
about that a little bit I we tend to be
quite transparent with the boys in that
you know they we don't want them to see
a life that is pain-free or glossed over
or you know not without anxiety or
challenge or whatever even though
there's a lot about our lives that is
anxiety free and challenge free and we
like admitting
to one another if we're pained if we're
chagrined if we're in some form or
another you know not not a Neve not in a
good mood as if for instance we're just
right I guess it's just again it's being
it's really trying to be honest with one
another I'm not sure ho parents do with
kids I don't know
and that we're in Outlook it's hard I
think is this children yeah it takes a
long time for you to understand that
your parents are human beings and that
they have their they have their faults
mm-hmm I think one of the reasons that
happens is that parents often try to
hide their faults from their kids
because you don't want you two kids to
see you in some human form right we try
not to do that I don't know I don't
that's not necessarily we don't
necessarily talk that way to one hey
let's show our faults our kids today I
think it's just the way you behave what
do you think looking at 15 years a CEO
of the Walt Disney Company and having
had many conversations certainly about
the these stories and learnings in your
book are there any particular lessons or
stories that you think and wish people
that pay more attention to I think more
than anything what I want people to come
away with is that from the outside
looking in this looks probably like a
straight line up from bottom to top you
know is sort of one step after the other
each step a step higher and
responsibilities authority compensation
whatever but it doesn't really happen
that way it's hard work and facing
unknowns and rising to challenges and
and and getting lucky and what I'm
trying to impart there more than
anything is even if it looks easy it's
not it always takes all sorts of other
elements including hard work
to to succeed at something I think I'm
not sure that I had anything else in
mind and that it also is not necessarily
part of a plan I don't think life is as
planned as young people think it is who
knows yeah that's another thing you
learn you know in their 60s and so I
often I got them struck off and people
say did you when did you want to be CEO
of the Walt Disney Company or did you
always want to be CEO of the Walt Disney
Company if I say you got to be kidding
me
of course not oh I didn't know I was
going to be CEO of the Walt Disney
Company until the board called me and
told me I was getting the job and they
didn't really want to be CEO or expect
that I could be until we were bought by
Disney in 1995 and I thought wow I'm now
part of a company that since I was at or
near running the company I was with
maybe the chance existed that I could
ultimately run the company I was now
owned by it wasn't until then it wasn't
something I grew up thinking about by
the way one thing you brought up that
you mentioned luck and people increasing
the opportunities for luck right we
talked about exercise the one thing that
strikes me there I don't think this is
necessarily about creating more
opportunities for luck but I'd have
found that oftentimes doors opened an
opportunity for people and not everybody
is able to walk through them for a
variety of reasons I've always been
really fortunate that whenever a door
opened meaning a door to opportunity I
walk through it I never walked away from
it and I don't know whether that is tied
to putting yourself on the line taking a
risk allowing yourself to be challenged
by new responsibilities and maybe
different form of scrutiny we're being a
fish out of water
I don't know but or even things as
simple as being willing to move I've
found a lot of people when doors open
they're not as capable of walking
through them
for whatever reason sometimes just by
the way self-doubt and by move you mean
just move forward or physically move no
I was even talking physically I'm
missing from New York to LA and from LA
to New York and from New York back to LA
and I said okay put me in that's an
opportunity I'm gonna take advantage of
but I have to move to get it now that's
the easier said than done
there are families at stake and I guess
you could argue that maybe I was selfish
that regard although that the sins were
never made unilaterally I had willing
spouses but I've also met a lot of
people that just said I know I'm not
going to do that no too risky for me to
move for and I was lucky in that regard
but what I'm also talking about is
people who are reluctant to take on
something new simply because they're not
sure of themselves and whether it's sort
of whether they'll finally be discovered
Yeah right and I never worried about
that oh boy he may be you know being
tested that's something else and what if
I'm not good are there any any books or
philosophers or leaders who you've not
necessarily directly but leaned on to
develop what strikes me as a very and I
mean this is a in the most positive
sense a very stoic philosophy when I was
reading for instance in your book about
meetings with the board and talking
about an inability to change the past
and looking forward to the future I mean
a lot of it resonates at least for me as
as very practical and and stoic very
kind of Marcus Aurelius like are there
any any kind of leaders or philosophies
or books that you've leaned on to help
you stay the course in this way and walk
through these doors of opportunity I've
never really read a business book in my
life
I read autobiographies they're a little
different though I I read and studied
Churchill carefully over the years
and he faced a tremendous amount of
adversity and doubters along the way and
and also unlike me he was involved in
some really colossal mistakes including
the tragedy at Gallipoli and the in the
the world free world were one era
for instance where he had the key of a
secretary of the Navy and he the onus
was on him the major naval disaster he
ran for and one ran for had lost more
elections than anyone else in the
history of Great Britain it says a lot
yeah it's like the Babe Ruth of British
politics yes I always was struck by
someone who from the outside or at least
history kind of shows him to be this
immensely successful world leader when
he wasn't always that way he got thrown
out of office actually as the Prime
Minister and came back and he only got
unelected at some point it came back and
saved Great Britain and maybe you could
argue the world from the throws of
Nazism he was thrown out again when the
war ended actually he was voted out when
the war ended and then came back again
anyway I I took a lot from him not sure
if there are others really now I've read
a lot over time a lot of biographies a
lot of a lot of novels as well Churchill
would be the only one I could think of
that stood out got it and saying
Churchill's a role models can a little
bit over the top and to itself and what
the heck right yeah well you've got
Churchill and then I suppose back in the
day Ian Fleming novels am I getting that
right did you read any Ian Fleming I did
I read I read most of his Bond novels
starting junior high school which would
have been the early 60s 63 60 62 63 64
yeah of course From Russia With Love
Goldfinger Spile of me you only live
twice sure I'll you fine and now you
have chronicles your own adventures in
the right of a lifetime which I really
recommend to people I think it gives a
window into as you said the the
nonlinear path that you have that you
have traveled and how it you've been
very very good at capitalizing on doors
opening to opportunities but it hasn't
necessarily reflected a grand 60 year
master plan for life right but you have
been really willing and able to step
through doors and take what others would
perceive as large risks do you have any
quotes I'll just ask a few more
questions do you have any quotes that
you think of often or try to live your
life by do any any quotes come to mind
and if not that's okay as well yeah well
the great one is the Teddy Roosevelt
quote about about fail if you're going
to fail fail during greatly you know
that book I do I can read it to you if
you like this please - go just want to
make sure I'm now calling it up because
I know it but I don't want to I don't
want to screw up on any part of it it's
not the critic who counts not the man
who points out how the strong man
stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man who was actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who airs who comes short again
and again because there is no effort
without error and shortcoming but who
does actually strive to do the deeds who
knows great enthusiasms great devotions
who spends himself in a worthy cause who
had best in the end the triumph of high
achievement I'm sorry who had best knows
in the end the triumph of high
achievement and who at worst if he fails
at least fails daring greatly so that
his place shall never be with those cold
and timid souls who know neither victory
nor defeat
it's that last part if he fails at least
fails while daring greatly so that his
place shall never be with those cold and
timid souls who know neither victory nor
defeat
it's so fantastic thank you for reading
that that is also that is also what
LeBron James has kept in his locker
since beginning his career it is huh
really it is it is uh yeah I did not
know that I gave that inscribed to all
senior management at the company many
years back oh what a great gift it is a
mantra of mine if and and I think it
says a lot about what I've done at least
if you're going to fail fail daring
greatly well I think that's I think
that's a fantastic place to wrap this up
and I also think that it's a that could
be the very very long subtitle the
option B for the ride of a lifetime this
book that I'm holding right in front of
me and this this is a bit a lot of fun
for me Bob I appreciate you taking the
time and is there anything else you'd
like to say or suggest to people any
parting comments anything at all that
you'd like to add before we before we
come to a close
no I enjoyed this thoroughly I think you
covered some really interesting topics
you you got under my hood a little bit
in a good way not in a way that made me
uncomfortable or at all or but I think
in a some things I haven't talked about
us specifically I know I enjoyed it
completely well thanks so much and for
people listening we're gonna have show
notes links to everything that we've
discussed including the book and
everything else in terms of resources at
tim dot blog forward slash podcast and
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
and would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday if that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird that
I've somehow dug up in the other world
of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
come that's four hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by humans
beat and elites the product is beat
elite not mute elite not beat the e 80
but beat beat eet elite which you might
consider an endurance superfood or what
they would call a nitric oxide activator
really all I care about is this product
feedly was introduced to me several
years ago by a multiple time world
champion and has since been recommended
to me by multiple world-class athletes
and I use it free workout for endurance
training that could be cycling
swimming it is very rarely running but
my subjective experience supports what
some of the research would seem to
indicate and that is that you can work
out say up to 15 to 18 percent longer if
you're looking at high-intensity
interval training hit for instance and
at recovery times so the let's call it
the refractory period for getting back
to a peak and power outlet for instance
so I use people they just use it this
morning before a 30 minutes somewhat
intense swim workout and I have found
that particularly for someone like
myself who has really terrible endurance
genetically speaking my presets are
horrible that it really does allow a 10
to 20 percent boost in shorter workout
performance especially although I do
know people who have used it for 20 mile
runs 30 miles much of those longer
endurance events and they've got all
sorts of different points about the
mechanisms of action and so on but
suffice to say that it is a lot easier
to consume feet leave than to meet the
nitric oxide equivalent of six whole
beats for instance much more rapidly
assimilated and it tastes great it will
also stain your pet polar bear or you
white cotton or your down pillows so to
put spill it on anything but it does
taste delicious I tend to mix this into
a shake that I have free workout in the
mornings so there you have it I've used
Italy for a number of years now it is
trusted by hundreds of elite teams
athletes and organizations all over the
world and it is also informed sport
certified which means that it is
certified to not contain any banned
substances so if you're a competitive
athlete that is one you were saying that
you need to worry about so take your
performance to the next level with beat
elite try it out go to live human calm
slash Tim to get 20% off your first
purchase the team at human this the
company is making this offer exclusive
to you my dear listeners so check it out
go to live human calm slash Tim super
simple live human calm slash Tim give it
a shot this episode of the Tim Ferriss
show is brought to you by 99designs
99designs is a global creative platform
makes it easy for you to find an amazing
designer and create designs you'll love
logos branding packaging the books you
name it they have it and I've used them
for just about everything 99 designs is
the go to creative resource for any
budget I've used them for years now for
book covers for instance mock-ups before
our body which went on to become a
number one era Times bestseller
illustrations for the multi volume towel
of Seneca including the cover and many
other creative projects I've been very
impressed by the quality of their work
most recently I used 99 designs to
update the illustrations and layout of
my 5 morning rituals eBook the
illustrations worked out great I loved
working with the designer was selected
and I plan to work with him on more
projects in the future and that's
something you can do you don't have to
start from scratch every time and right
now my listeners can get $20 off plus a
free $99 upgrade on their first design
contest simply submit a brief on the
site describing what you need and
designers who are interested in your
project often from around the
will submit concepts for you to choose
from if you were find as you go give
feedback and once you're ready you
choose one to finalize it's a great way
to get started and find the right match
a great designer and a great design at a
great price so head to 99designs comm
forward slash Tim to learn more or get
started today you can also see examples
of some of the work that I have done
with designers on on that size let's
check it out 99designs comm forward
slash tip
you
[Applause]